hello happy Friday everybody hey guys
I'm Eric I'm joined by Sam got some new
blood in the stream room Sam for all the
people that don't know who you are in
the game straw community here what do
you do for us here at GameSpot so for
the last better part of the last year I
have been doing social media with
GameSpot
and I definitely helped run the Facebook
Instagram Twitter Apple news but ever
you would find us basically I have a
hand in that awesome cool and so part of
bringing you on today is cuz I recall
during extra life you had a pretty good
pretty good couple runs actually in pub
G and it's kind of a slow January and we
haven't actually checked out the desert
map on the stream so I figure you know
let's test your skills a little bit
maybe we hunt some chicken dinners
hopefully in the desert but here we go I
had just moved to San Francisco yeah and
I hadn't played in like six weeks okay
Wow so it was it was already a good run
that was a rusty top ten oh alright well
they will see we'll try I mean like
that's that's the hope
so the desert map should come up you
know for the most part and then and if
not and we get the old map well just go
to the school or something go crazy so I
actually have a question George because
I haven't seen this mode before one-man
squad now I haven't played a ton of one
point oh yeah I have almost 100 hours in
the game but I just haven't seen this
version yeah what is this one-man squad
I'm not even sure myself I'm the I'm
actually like one of the noobs of pub G
in the office I watch a lot but uh but
then you know alright don't play maybe
after the first solo game depending on
how far we get in I might try it try out
a one-man squad it's if it is what it
sounds like fancy solo to me but I don't
you know we could we could we go mess
around
we're gonna start matchmaking we'll see
what happens yeah it's gonna be fine
Oh also just so you guys know I'll be in
the chat I was someone saying don't do
hey what's up thanks for coming to the
stream so there you go oh so you might
run into a team of four but you're by
yourself you should leave em a it's hard
mode if you're if you feel it like
you're you want to try that out more
power to you I'm I'm just gonna you know
be over here do anything I don't know if
I'm like thugged-out enough for that
right now
that's alright you got a couple matches
under your belt and maybe that'll like
instill confidence and then you'll be
like you know what let's go do this no
problem
hardmode pub G doesn't matter if they
got squads cuz you're a one-man wrecking
machine one woman man reckons if I was
to actually try the one man I I kind of
wanted to you the one man squad sure I
but the thing is I'm gonna go total
pacifist
I'm just gonna try to win the game like
you're in a tournament eSports
tournament style well no I'm just gonna
like the last like ten or something like
when the ring gets really small right
you just like chill on the outskirts
don't just lay low just like prone to
snake your way yeah a little crater
what's up thanks for dropping by
yeah they have faith in you they say you
got this
so we'll see okay no pressure Sam you
know so I'm still pretty new to the
desert map I know that loosely on the
hotspot I imagine that there's some
other what would you like in that to to
like the old map what's what's the
equivalent lost Leona's because I know
more of the old man up with [ __ ]
okay got it thanks Khaleesi plays that's
a Khaleesi plays you should have it on
periscope just so you know we're also
sending out to periscope so you guys are
tuning in to periscope thank you for
that I should bonita loca
cuz living Leben needs a look at it
looks dangerous because you're in this
crater which by the way this is pretty
cool this is like an a meteor hit I
guess at one point in time and now it
looks like it so the the crater is
dangerous because people who get out of
here or people who land outside of here
are gonna be able to snipe you down when
you get up over that crust yeah so that
yeah it's a crash site is what is it a
Turkish I'm serious
I'll Turkish thank you for correcting me
yeah he they had just mentioned that it
was a crash site and we got to see that
that's pretty cool man so I'm looking
forward to kind of checking out the
desert man I haven't seen too much of it
there's some like new vehicles to I
think like a bus that can't make it up a
hill have you seen that gear it's like
one of the new vehicles on the desert
map they can't make it up the hill so
then like they're like what if we get
out and try to push it and it actually
like kind of works so let's see
say hi to periscope all 630 hi periscope
there's 7:30 now what's up hopefully Sam
says she has no rust I'm just kidding
it'll be fine have you played this on
Xbox at all yet I have it's it's pretty
rough I played on an Xbox
not one X the one X is performs a little
bit better so if you're gonna try to
play it at all hopefully you have a One
X okay then you're definitely playing on
PC then yeah I mean unless the rumors
are true right hmm they say that it
might be coming it's probably yeah who
knows when that'll happen but yeah Sam
did you know you could vault now I did
and I was so exciting I played last
night with halting for the first time Oh
like I said I just moved I just got
Internet it just got back from holiday
so I was like very excited sweet what's
up Jacob Janney and periscope hi hello
Jayden's app says every time they play
on xbox it crashes I didn't have crashes
but it
had some it had some jank and aiming is
definitely not as precise on a
controller as it is on a mouse keyboard
obviously just really want anything so
you're saying you're not living you
don't like the DualShock yeah I mean the
dual shotgun life is like yeah it's you
know so surprisingly I feel like
shotguns are actually really good on
console only because aiming is so tough
that like you end up like at least in
close quarters it's like alright well I
mean you want to use a shotgun close
quarters on PC to buy like I don't know
I feel like I've seen like Nick get a
lot of kills on Xbox with I personally
one of my favorite guns is a shotgun
it's Auto shotgun its s12 kay I love
that thing love it I just you don't even
have that right now you're I don't even
have that I got this stupid single oh
what's that probably no no but I can
turn up our audio so again there you go
okay yeah so I guess in a way you're
kind of playing handicapped because you
have to talk the whole time while trying
to hear footsteps I guess I'll just like
no no you're fine I don't mind I played
when I was playing for extra with
actually on our live stream I can feel
like I keep hearing stuff I think it's
just the sound of my own walking like a
spooked cat oh all right I'm trying to
turn Sam's mic up a little bit but I'll
also just tell her to talk a little
louder
yeah can you guys hear me if I can now
okay also I also boosted your mic a
little bit oh great if if that doesn't
work you just have to be a little bit
louder
I made your normal indoor voice
I'll have to get really close to the
microphone and talk in a deeper voice oh
yeah yeah yeah it's not I don't think
this maps on console the Sonia chat can
correct we are dead center of the circle
like literally bull's eye dead center I
don't even have to leave this place if I
don't want to I could chill here
probably for the rest of the game sleuth
your way oh wait look there's a job are
you gonna I got such a sweet deal right
now oh good a helmet I don't know why I
didn't take that the first time I didn't
see it either that's that's a rookie
mistake on my part
yeah what's up I'm in the TV how are you
doing mr. chair let's go up here and see
see anybody oh oh no okay I'm just gonna
continue to loot this area sorry guys
it's part of it's part of the pub G like
stop anyone that has played this game
knows that that is is the thing yeah a
Taurus says if you're going to play
passive you can climb the wreckage of
the airplane and get one of those
destroyed houses is this art what is the
one thing you gun there's a couple new
guns right yeah I just I it looks so
strange I'm probably never gonna use it
I just took it I do that a lot I like to
pick up every single attachment that I
find because I'm so yeah some
attachments I'm really bad at reminding
remembering like which guns they go to
so I'm just like I'm not doing that
right now though that's fine that pistol
is the best one on this map thank you
yay use the 0.45 and a red dot thanks
for the tip where are the chickens I
don't know yeah we're hunting I don't
know what's this 194 s can somebody who
it loves this game tell me if this gun
is any good I'll just I believe you yeah
ok so did you get their tip though like
climbing fire yeah
I'm the that crashed the record vault
okay wait no it's bad John Luke are you
saying the shotguns bad he's rising the
handgun that little bit because 45 cents
I like that yeah mo I mean that yeah
it's just not that great I guess there
was a sniper rifle that takes no sights
or something that we might have would
have been that uh might have been that
uh that gun you were looking at there
you're like what gun is this unless that
yeah cuz you don't you definitely don't
have us those are not snipers so much it
might not matter though right well
actually my down the road yeah I mean
look they don't suck that like it's not
we're not in like a if I got somebody it
would be fine unless they had like an
auto rifle then I would be dead probably
unless I shot them like point-blank in
the head they weren't wearing a helmet
or for some reason they don't have a
best baby you know it's really dicey you
don't happen to me yesterday last night
I was going to this game and I had
always I've been through so many red
zones I can't even tell you how many red
zones I've gone through safely
I was almost like these red zones are
really stupid it's like yeah like I've
gone through some some tension I mean it
adds a little bit of tension but I had
never suffered in a red zone before I've
never actually been a victim of the red
zone tell Sam to look sorry tell Sam to
look down the side of the Winchester and
fire it this is not
we're talking about this thing
why am I going to give away my location
I don't what am I gonna do because its
face palms I can I've gotten to the
point now where I've lost track no the
first gun is that the first gun oh this
one yeah why do I want to fire this
right no cuz what do I know
isn't that one of your trusty chat
people I mean do I trust him I don't
know you told me that I did really
personally don't trust that because chat
finds ways to burn me but well no that
doesn't mean that I'm safe we are
currently playing on PC - where is it
Murdoch 187 2007 on periscope yeah some
of us are hoping for ps4 but like
personally I think if you can play on a
PC plan a PC instead of console at least
for pub G for sure this guy says what a
pro a dilute I know I'm alluding a
little sloppily I'm really not paying
attention to where I'm going
that's fine look nobody shot at us
nobody's found us it's fine look but am
i alive though that's what I have to say
all right like personally on the inside
or like yeah here's that other shotgun
for the asado
it's like a handgun shotgun very
confused but hey hey those happen those
are an action movies you know handgun
shotguns yeah like a real short you know
like a long barreled handgun oh like
it'd be dating myself I nope not gonna
go there do like like either Dirty Harry
or like yes like Charles Bronson type
thing no ways here I know maybe they're
all over and lost Leona's oh I got
scared of my own shadow who's that oh
it's me
yeah oh I heard a gun shop it was pretty
far away just kidding that was your
mouse this yeah I'm just in her head now
at this point yeah that's what happens
when there's not enough action for a
long time you start to get like jumpy
you're just like okay what's gonna
happen well because it's been like dead
quiet yeah sorry Bob no ways here
normally though for trouble I know
they're just saying that um you gotta
close all those doors behind you it's
like it's you can that sure but Oh pain
killers now if I just leave them all
open they're like okay somebody's here
but we have no idea where because all
the doors are open oh god yeah and then
also it's like Oh everything's looted
why do i I'm not even gonna bother
looking in the houses anymore should I
can't to a plane I thought you were
listening perhaps I mean I was just
looking around really Jake deck also are
Jakob Decker who plays a bunch says I
only shut doors near the end sometimes
leaving them open is a good strategy yes
on the same page it's all it's all you
know you gotta feels it out all I
remember was when I was playing on xbox
with Jake I was like Jake what do I do
Jake where do I go what are the buttons
Jake Jake Lewis Steven this is the first
game of the day this would I'm just
gonna say this is the warm-up but if it
ends up being a nice little finale then
we didn't really need the warmup I'm
just good exactly but it leaves lead
leeway and an out you know all right
we're going to that airplane I guess I
don't know I haven't I don't think I
went inside or around at the front of it
so check it out okay is this I have a
question for Jake the wind 94 do I drop
this is this garbage tell me I think
people were saying the Winchester was
bad but let's confirm or deny that chat
that plays the the pub G's is the
Winchester garbage and do we need to
drop it there all everybody I feel like
people who really in pubs you'd like oh
it's situational that's that can't be
true and also like some of these some of
the guns I mean like even if there are
ones that are better than others
some people just like certain guns Jacob
says it's it's trash all right thank you
we gonna drop it
see ya maybe some poor sucker will pick
it up and you know yeah now I got this
single shotgun this is cool all right
I'm getting like antsy idea but then our
Turkish says until you have something
you can put a site on it and keep
there's a sniper rifle so okay well that
would have been it we're gonna hand
handgun and shotgun our way through this
why drop it because it's it's over
birdie one time I dropped a yeah that's
good I remember I was uh this was extra
life dream I was playing and I dropped
my I didn't I per was an annex scope it
was like the final ten and I dropped in
somebody was like why and I was like
what's the final ten I'm not gonna use a
sniper rifle with an 8x okay this is
some people were saying that a good some
people were saying that you might have
wanted to keep it just in case only
because you don't have a ranged weapon I
have nothing good right now basically
yeah are you still yeah are you still
gonna hang out here I don't know you you
made out okay you got a couple boosts
you don't have like a first aid but you
got a you got a level two helmet I want
to see you have a little two vest so
like good it could be worse baby it's
real like someone saying we 94 is not a
sniper rifle it's just a rifle that's
fine I should just do crowbar strat and
just like try to machete people my [ __ ]
day those are two different weapons that
you can use in this game but it's the
same essentially yeah turn this game to
a hack and slash key matches I had a
mode where you only were given melee
weapons how about you only cross
crossbow like once I turned it until I
got double-oh-seven you know like you
get to choose your
a first aid kit a level two vests
alright we're moving on up now we just
need an AR what's this house okay let's
see me be in here give me a right here
I'm lame
wait maybe no well it could've been
worse as I'd like to say you know a lot
of people are saying well not a lot but
a couple be worth saying like I should
have held on to the win oh is it red
zone guys this is scary okay so I
actually got like it just it was just
kinda scary
and then last night I was playing and I
got hit by the by the wreck yeah never
happened to me before there's always a
first time for everything I was
seriously like I was blown away I was
like maybe they may or maybe they caught
on maybe they made it you know more
dangerous to go through the red because
all right Bob don't worry I'll turn off
the the donate thing okay do we go to
the graveyard or do we go to I probably
should try to get to some of these
buildings on the outskirts honestly so
because of the way the plane was there's
gonna be more people coming up and
especially because this is such a hot
place to go there's gonna be a lot of
people coming up from the south part of
the map so if I go up a little bit like
towards here it's probably not that bad
of an idea although you do you follow
your heart follow my heart
yep my heart would just lock me up in
one of these buildings waiting for some
idiot to come inside
but yeah I'm bored and I like danger oh
the ATD is kicking in yeah basically I
this sucks it was like if I if I get
caught out coming up over this Lake the
crest of this hill like um I'm toast
I'm toasty toasty roasty toasty all
right so we're looking for some
potential action and or at least an AR
or maybe any type of rifle to be honest
well we had a rifle
whoops geez all right okay let's try
this over here
doors will closed hello Fred ger they
also supplied this how do you Sam
what's up Fred thanks for stopping by
afraid was was and look all these little
oh okay I'm gonna get rid of all these
quick all those asking her name is Sam
and she run are bunch of socials
different social platforms here yeah but
uh I'll just leave it as a blanket
general statement so then I don't have
to get into it or you could scrub back
to the beginning of this video where I
asked him what she does at GameSpot and
she tells you all the things she does
for games watch I do the Facebook's the
Twitter's the instagrams the well we
have a big team that everybody helps you
out with this stuff so I'm a cog in the
social machine but I'm not a machine
yeah where people Sam I can get my strim
I haven't streams like I said in a while
because the move but you know her twitch
if you guys are curious when she
inevitably does start streaming again I
switched on TV slash light hammer Li gh
T hammer har that's how you say my last
name by the way yeah not like how my how
would you how would I don't know I
probably would have liked through a some
egregious like oh okay how fortuitous
Oh oh right okay okay I hopefully know
it's coming from no don't say that have
to believe what happens when you die you
lose the round Nikolas though but the
good thing and the biggest thing for
about pop G is the fact that you can
pretty much just like restart again like
pretty quickly oh oh you scared the crap
you're getting shot at
oh and there's another package over
there you're fine serpentine they want
that package oh this this is no don't no
no I believe I believe you got it one of
the like that I feel like it's like the
AWP of pop G even though it probably
isn't but that sniper is supposed to be
pretty good
I think are you good with snipers you
might want to reload your yeah MP - yeah
there you go I don't know what they're
following or not Sam is not the
numérique ish that's not how this works
don't you do that to her - Sam or to
Mary not fair
load your guns we're loading them right
it was good all right what do you got
for your nice 8x scope okay that's fine
nothing wrong with boosting always be
boosting okay oh is that oh that's their
car huh yeah I think oh here let me turn
up the audio for you hold on
I did okay
I thought someone shot at you there's
also a drop behind you maybe people are
around there too so be careful thanks
Jake yeah I know this is veno gaming
we're not wearing a little sticky
situation we're in between two drops in
a house she got the goods from the first
drop the I think it's the awm shoot okay
so here okay I know I'm in a window oh
no I'm not it is very nerve-racking this
is gonna be so dicey
it's like backseat gaming Oh God oh yeah
I didn't know you could do that I did
not know you could do that it was a cat
we're fine there's only 17 alive we're
doing well when she dropped it it reset
two single fire your UMP just so you
know go full order right thank you
Thanks way to see that I'm looking at
Chad I got I got nothing for her if I
just like go right now I feel like I'm
putting myself in such a position of
vulnerability this car feels like being
lit so much oh you think so
yeah they don't take the car then do you
have to take the car is a circle closing
in it's kinda in two minutes
oh you hear that
Jake wants to know if you can get the
car
oh it's a motorcycle do you think
they're gonna go for the car oh this is
this is awkward I have no idea where you
getting shot from behind yeah I'm 16
they were in that house
dang it 15 not bad I didn't kill it oh
good thing that death was saved - thanks
Nvidia right right that wasn't you oh
he's got a ghillie suit oh so he saw you
yeah they totally saw it oh man what a
spot you're the palm tree here I know
just like oh look you want to hang out
there
[Music]
that's all right not bad you didn't kill
anyone
but you know 15 I probably would have
died a lot sooner but that's because I
have decided to go to the crash site it
was just like it's alright one of those
games oh yeah good thanks
save my death Yeah right so I can relive
it forever yeah like like like a play of
the game overwatch mode or something
yeah all right
so how you feel warmed up now yeah you
know we're gonna do I think this time
we'll do solo will do I like spicy spicy
all right we're going in guns blazing
sounds good alone so I just five minutes
ago are you in the mines Alonso are you
in the salt mines right now I would be
yes
some people saying I need that ps4 pub
she is now yeah hopefully it's sooner
than we think what yeah it's hard to say
when it comes to shooters I'm just
always better with PC yeah I mean it
says more precision also if you're just
used to playing FPS games or you know
third-person whatever yes on a PC like
you're definitely getting better in with
Mouse like even for me playing destiny
on PC I definitely feel the difference I
also feel better just started playing
this the uneasy oh guys are you enjoying
that first time playing destiny in
general or I started with
oh my god my my brain the first DLC that
came out for the person taking care okay
that's a good time to start out yeah
that was when I started and I played a
Titan
oh no that's class yes I played a
striker cyan mostly yeah
but I was just bad it's because well do
you play for PvP or PvE I wanted to play
and I wanted to be able to also this
looks like a school drop but alright
we're doing it oh is the old man that's
fine we're going in guns blazing um
Alonso says yeah he's digging deep in
the mines I feel you man I feel you
that's that's some time investment to
only get second feels feels bad but it's
part of the reason why people play Poggi
to get the chicken dinner yes you're
damn right
been Janka best class yes so this time
around I actually made a warlock oh
sweet warlocks very solid Hunter has got
the got that oh there's a lot
it's basically who gets onto the school
top first and who gets the guns first oh
good luck to you I am NOT gonna be
first-year yeah I watch a decent amount
I are watched more puffs GE when it was
like this map and not so much the desert
map and yeah this place gets a little
crazy we'll see what happens oh you do -
it's a scar give us a gun oh he's like
oh he's so dead oh he's got pistol well
played well played
I didn't even save the kill oh yeah oh
it does save the kill we're gonna find
out might have hit you once I think
there's someone on your left like he hit
me once I think somebody hit me behind
from behind
alright we'll find out yeah that's how
we landed what into the water okay was
that no that's not you just freak dating
someone now what I guess it was too soon
the game couldn't oh I know that's you
okay so was this guy
oh man what you know what okay so people
talk so much bad about that pistol
that's the pistol that takes seven six -
yeah I look like okay I love watching
this like where where where where's how
how did he did he wanted you and like
bend the bullet around the like I don't
know I I don't see how he killed you
there but maybe I'm missing something
there I don't know man I don't know it
looked like he shot me through or [ __ ]
looked like it went yeah she it looked
like I went through but then unless it
somehow went right over and well try
again that's the beauty of pub G it
doesn't matter school is a bad place no
it's it's fun to get spicy action spicy
action hold on do I do this
do what then one man squad that's your
call you if you want to do the hardcore
mode it's it's totally up to you are you
gonna play it slow are you gonna go you
kind of go yeah maybe to end the stream
okay
one man squad two industry will do this
solo yeah that sounds good build it up
you know yes yes I probably will jump
into a man squad run into a squad
immediately and then and kill them all
yes yeah that's exactly where I was
going
you know though I have actually gotten a
squad killed before really yes it was
nice so stupid
I dropped it Milt a power plant in one
of those warehouses okay and got the
scar put on auto had a ton mo sat in a
corner and one after one this was just
one after one of those there's squats
lying about I got separated from my
squad so they were you know what that's
reduce you might been in this game I
don't remember if you were or not but
this was this was a good game and yeah I
got the five kills in a row that's sweet
that feels good it was nice
Subban Chris RKO yes we are reading the
chat so send
your questions or comments and if
they're pertinent I will read them hello
Jose Benitez welcome to the stream
hopefully you guys are all having a good
Friday yes we're having a good Friday
we're just hanging out at work playing
pub gee can't complain
thank you all for helping support us
yeah thanks for the warm welcome
everybody and if you guys want to see
more streams like this or play a bunch
of different games games that you know I
have like betas you know games that are
coming out sometimes we get them early
make sure you hit that sub button on
YouTube or that like button on Twitch
and follow us so that you guys know when
we go live we go live every day at 11
a.m.
hold on I think I'm gonna drop over this
bridge is like really cool a little
island it's probably not a place you
actually want to be but you know but it
could be like that island in the other
map right there's a lot of goodies yes
it looks like there is a power plant
little island all the way over there is
that where the game starts that's
probably where the game starts alright
we're gonna go on a little trip
sounds like a boat okay hello mr. turtle
you're gonna go all the way back to what
we think is the starting point yes that
oil rig looking place yes okay
that's only if we can find a boat look
at the water oh there's a boat over
there oh my god alright
when does Norman Reedus baby game come
out who knows 20 or something like that
oh my god Albert Einstein hi play more
puppy we can try we easily we used to do
Poggi more frequently back when it was a
Mike and Jake I know Mike actually is on
the Rainbow six siege train now is he
yeah he's really gotten into that game
Jake still plays but oh man I'm so
excited I love this so much you have no
idea sweet we're gonna go on a little a
little journey we're gonna go on a
cruise together guys cruise dang I'm so
good yeah so if we do more puppy in the
future maybe I just have Jake Oh with
Sam maybe they can alright let's see you
know what I'm gonna mark it oh you can't
mark it okay I'm just gonna go where I
think it is try rowdy mueslix we will
stream Monster Hunter the new Monster
Hunter world when it comes out I think
there's another beta right before it
actually comes out so you'll probably
see us doing that I think there's new
monsters
Fred grrrrrr my name is Eric - yeah Fred
could you not be any more new here
that's okay we invite new people all the
time should have grabbed a weapon from
those houses there I'm 95% sure that you
cannot get there
so are you hey we have a five percent
chance five percent chance yeah my
sights we're heading straight there I
probably won't have enough gas to get
back yeah like look let's just hope for
a the circle to favor us in any way
shape or good Albert Einstein get it
says get a gun we'll get a gun after we
do our touring our crews here hello and
I'm gonna push her this is it Sekou
David from Venice Italy not be very
sport kick halt sorry
we'll find out you can correct me on how
to say your name but thank you for
tuning in for me to leave that's awesome
you know I always wonder if they hide
random stuff in the water
Oh invisible wall sham wow you're really
stuck in a game alright experiment over
well that was fun you got close in the
original map you can go to the island
where you start yeah so that's why I
thought
super realistic yeah
also apparently the the the circle is
not favoring not at all I'm just gonna
try to get back I'm gonna try to get
onto this island there actually were
some cars over there
so I don't know let's see I'm gonna try
to get de zon to land
sounds good I find a car I'll go
somewhere like really out we shall see
yeah the world is your oyster you choose
what ya rlm says a new monster hunter
world beta is gonna have the near ghonte
near good gun my if you say that long
close which is crazy tough and also the
flagship monster for the game in Japan
that he's excited to play it and see the
game swap he would play yeah
probably have been or John Luke or the
combination on there playing let's see
hello from Mexico says one dabs a lot
you dab a lot one well hello and hello
ela or is it l3 from Portugal Thank You
Eli 3d likely or open alright we're
gonna get up over here on this Beach
your gun let's get a gun oh we know yeah
yeah we're gonna be fine I need a car
really more than anything right now
actually I mean the gun is like
important as well don't get me wrong but
you're gonna die Circle yeah if I don't
get find a vehicle we're kind of out of
luck
deadly Edie as Fred would say GED dead
rip all right Ripper he knows your lives
I'll take mini easy easy looking for
transportation where are you dear
motorcycling I'm gonna do this for 19
more seconds okay wow that's very
precise oh you're giving yourself
immediate to go over to the toilet paper
TP is that your abbreviation for toilet
paper oh I thought that you were calling
somebody in the chat no no okay all
right unless there is someone in the
chat named TP but I doubt it so you can
just like break through witness paper so
once that vehicle was right there all
right well no did you mean ma I feel
like I think I just got trolled
yeah there's literally a vehicle there
but it's all know still good given the
shake and bake shake it before you bake
it terrible shame oh good you're good
oh they had the same idea as you or you
try to take their car and say hey let's
not oh man you're out in the open
you're asking for trouble I don't I this
is he's your tactics are gonna confuse
him that's the point
lol they were above you well we're fine
stay mighty because their aim was quite
poor it was very very poor I have no
health
let's see that's fine this is fine
everything's fine oh not sure ciao
Freitas yeah
I suspect take the game after you die um
I think you can only expect 8 if we
really in a squad together ok see you
later sucker
Oh maybe please please that's not that's
also wait is it no no also now I don't
know but you got your this is going
great yeah I agree so Chris I agree we
are yes it could be it could be worse
though a lot of our previous says that
the the circle will kill you don't man
come on she could bandage
do I have bandages oh no I don't know if
you have time to bandage I think that's
the least of your worries right now all
right
let's hope that's a bus that I can drive
over there someone saying rip womp womp
I'm like high heart that vehicle all
caps you know I actually could survive
that if I just walk towards it but I
think that that's a vehicle that I can
drive I'm really hoping it is that that
if that's the bus that thing sucks we're
gonna party bus that's the slow bus I
know someone's a party bus so you can't
say party bus like normal all you got to
say it's somewhat it enthusiastic
striker look you haven't seen me in
action yet okay look yeah yeah you know
what I mean no I'm not even gonna
pretend why are you running in the
middle of the road yeah because we
adhere to the rules with James alright
we got it we got to get somewhere in a
bus that can't climb Hills
you know I haven't even been in combat
yet I like ran away from one guy who
shot at me and he didn't even follow
through he let me lose he probably was
like man I can't I'm not gonna kill so
might as well get to the to the toilet
circle or something stepping on it
stepping on the gas yeah we're going at
max speed yes that is true arrow and we
have not seen Sam's final form yes I
have yet to evolve or yet to lose some
type of close friend or family member to
then cause you to turn into your final
form right that's the enemy way yep
Krillin dies and then you go ssj that's
just what it has to happen sometimes
spoilers all right do we have time to
loot this house yeah Mike on the edge
all right like I said you'd know better
than me no I mean I didn't oh look a
first aid kit that's what we need we do
need a first aid kit
don't mind us relax striker she's not
gonna die at least not yet
ooh well bandage action we'll take that
so you didn't have bandages by the way
so I was wrong I think I was recalling
your last game I don't have a helmet so
I'm gonna put this hat on everything
what's this a yeah that'll protect you
at least I can die cool like a slow moan
and a hat flies off your head right yes
get the hot boosts hot boosts allistic
massive mask as well because really we
need us a assault rifle
[Music]
will we find some more loot or will this
house probably dead come on that's
supposed to be a pile of guns I don't
even need that attachments picked it up
that's like a really bad habit of mine
and I will always pick up the
attachments I don't need guys I'm sorry
I'm sorry sorry but not sorry
I'll have by the time I'm done I'll have
five SMG flash hiders at least the
person that Lutz your dead body assuming
you die will be like oh I needed that
that's a rock thought it was loot all
right we're just bleeding out a little
bit no problem okay all right climate so
I've abandoned my van but I'm not really
sad about that you know that's fine yeah
we definitely left the bus it's it's
we're looking we're looking to move up
in the world get a car yeah - soccer
soccer mom forever all right I'm gonna
make my way I'm actually gonna play not
I'm not gonna go towards the city I'm
gonna play on this side okay you're
gonna try to get to those smaller houses
and hope for the hope for the best
Sarah's probably looted anyways can you
drive the tractor trailers or I think
that's like to meme worthy oh there's a
there's a da see over there oh well
what's will you do yeah I should
probably go get the dossier now we want
to get that exercise dark squad hello
what are you guys playing this weekend
looks like your go-to game right now
that was directed to chat not I feel
like yeah I'm not oh wait it's a pickup
no dasya is it looked I guess in the
distance I thought it looks like a jasja
my ojos deceived me neo says razz Raza
Klaus that's a good game solid game why
did I leave the bus Oh No
ruiner for Artigas Assassin's Creed
origins for in theory so Chris is
playing IKEA this weekend nice it's all
a game I played IKEA last weekend okay
there is an IKEA game though or like
what that's like like it's like a joke
game is there yeah that's pretty funny
Meritage is saying pokey and they are
billions have you seen their billions no
but I saw choco bars with streaming it
yesterday and I it looked interesting
yeah it looks cool I'm not sure if it's
a game that I would play but I had it on
like forgot who I was watching um might
have been like Co carnage or something
like that on the side just like trying
to see what the game was and I was like
oh that's cool
I guess I could kind of watch that but
I'm not into those the doors are open
here yeah well you know I thought you
weren't going to this big city I've
changed my mind
okay sure archangels 0 3 says Skyrim
horizon zero dawn overwatch and warframe
also all games all solid games mr.
turtles cod World War 2 Eduardo's gonna
play some prey there was a car to your
left that's not I got to stop reading
chat believing everything they say was
that I mean maybe I don't know I just
dropped and picked up a gun that's the
same exact gun I'm going to avoid this
time to play the left also Sam let's go
right nice l-3
I like the decision
oh well there's a definitely a car now
guys
and it drops coming
Pedro boy geek culture and tech test
into Witcher 3 mr. turtle st. destined
to
are you guys going to be playing
Dragonball fighters when it comes out
definitely 100% I kind of wish to that
game and another bus I didn't even need
the other bus I kind of wish that
Monster Hunter and Dragon Ball weren't
coming out on the same day but that's
just how it goes sometimes touched my
necks aka our CRISPR era of the news
team's gonna play some paladin in God of
War have you uh you seen that did you
see that paladin's has like a pub do you
style like I I did see that I still have
played any paladin's those are the
Battle Royale thing is hot guys look I
buses a plenty seriously oh yeah look
another bus have you played the
fortnight idol real at all um I have not
played yeah I haven't either
so because a lot like most of the
comparison so far like 52 or probably
that Dragon Ball Fighters yes Albert
Einstein Oh can't get up it it's trying
real hard stepping on it mr. Smith yes
there was no lobby this week and there
might not be one next week either we're
in a little bit of a break and some
people are out so we're just kind of
catching up also we're doing some minor
tweaks to like our control room and
stuff like that in the studio so we're
just catching up so yeah one out of ten
do not recommend here's a fun one crazy
I have a 99 asking do you think anthem
will be good so good still good
flips itself back up no problem
right crazy Ivan I'm not sure it looked
cool and like the this kind of like
staged demo because like I don't think
it was like like people actually playing
it it's like probably like a pre done
demo it looked good but I have no idea
it's hard to say
also EA okay Khaleesi plays says nailed
it's stuck the landing
nice good park job a little a little
back and forth here some people like in
the fortnight more than pub G some
people like pub do more than fortnight
wargames the better it's fine like you
know and we live in a good time right
now where there's a lot of good games to
play you know I've watched a little bit
of the fortnight's yeah and it just you
know I get I get why doesn't like where
the similarities live but I also feel
like it looks like a totally different
game yeah Tommy gun yeah you sound so
enthused oops I didn't want the crossbow
though that was really a mistake okay
yeah or although I'm not sure if there
will be one next week we'll see let's
see okay I guess we'll go up I kinda
want to be on the edge of the road here
I'm cautiously optimistic crazy Ivan but
I don't I don't know I'll wait till we
actually get like some hands-on time
with with anthem before kind of trying
to make judgments based off like one
gameplay demo that they showed at e3
maybe it'll show more of it this year
hard to say but Johnny we'll see
Oh No
oh my god twitch staff yeah it's which
staff is in the house
but it's just grossest neurosis is uh is
the old buddy I guess so Chris - yeah
yep yeah they both got that wrench
neurosis is a old actually was kind of
my old boss at one point but yeah you
used to work at the GameSpot's
Oh any news about pub G my name is not
Chow it's more like it reads like Kyle
okay Kyle I'll just say Kyle because
then it's closer it's like I would have
butchered Sam's last name that's what I
yeah something like that you know there
was a time my life was gonna change my
last name really yeah look at it what do
you mean it's there there are so many
worse last names like for example Nick
was telling me the other day like
there's a there's a football player that
plays for I think it was Michigan or
something in college and his last name
is but wait no
his last name is but yeah it's either bu
TT or but it's either but man and
apparently he's actually really good at
football but it's just like it's it's a
terrible last name right so compared to
his his compared to yours I think yours
is a lot better somebody was in here
also apparently there's another guy
that's on that team oh there's a helmet
there by the way
there's another guy on that team oh it's
already kind of damaged but there's
another guy on that team too and his
last name is gross so apparently he said
like on the sidelines at some point
they're standing next to to each other
and so it read gross but exactly
I hear car I don't know where it's
driving from apparently geek cultures in
Texas at work we have a lady and that
her last name is big ones no joke oh my
god I think how long's do a supreme
opinion wants to know roughly how long
the rounds last with a hundred I guess
it depends on how long you survive
how long do you think like if you're
gonna win a chicken dinner roughly like
how much time do you think that is I
mean I would say like 35 minutes by man
if you make it to the end
but it could be as short as like a
minute like in that other school Fiasco
right also okay there rusty I thought
that was amazing
look at all these rusty old bikes
everywhere it's a mind game you okay
let's thoughts on park r5 asking bike
event asked by a Viking fan I haven't
played it there's a couple people in the
office that had gone to go check it out
so you probably have to ask them or I'll
ask them next time for car five yeah
which I think it's delayed ooh moving on
up moving on up we're not living that
poverty life in it get rid of this SMG
smoke grenade yeah I do it okay sixteen
people I mess with it what will happen
who knows we need a better helmet we
need really better everything and okay
we're rocking with very mediocre
everything right now oh look our Turkish
wants you to drop ammo you don't need
later but stop tell me how to live my
life they only want the best for you I
know I know it's fine for now I think
because it's not like you have that much
- oh okay why why is this in here why
are these in here yeah but if you could
get out that'd be so sad actually like
the funniest thing it's like it's
actually a trap in the game
now he'll know it's a rock yeah well
there's a lot of buildings at least
there are tons of buildings here it's
given me a little bit of anxiety
watermelon ssj4 wants to know if GTA 5
is still I would pretty sure it is they
added like the DeLoreans and the rocket
packs that allow you to fly around watch
out who will win okay switching the SMG
okay he's running away he did not like
they have the tactical advantage you had
I guess 13 that better than last time
first guy running - I just ran hey man
he was fully kitted okay to run around
the building and then run straight out
off the road so I thought I was gonna
get to shoot him in the back I promise
that's what that's fine it's good to
know the play-by-play in your head and
understand the thought process there for
now they understand the chat understands
of why we made the move that we made
that's why do we have to want to watch
it it's gonna hurt me to watch it all
right and why don't you give me the
play-by-play then if you're gonna do it
play the death cam and then give us a
play-by-play as you just did but now in
real will have the actual like you know
replay here alright here comes the other
guy just looting
oh no I see somebody oh that was when
you're switching things right and then
like he's gonna code this way and run
over that way that's what I thought he
was gonna do
but really he baited you it's alright
it's okay
the beauty of pubs you look I hate to
prove you right this game but I'll give
it this this one to you this one
everyone gets one Korena spider-man and
Family Guy she gets 13th ranked on a
Friday the 13th
oh all right here we go
what are you gonna go for here are we
gonna do the syntax error said you got
played like a fiddle
I did get played like a fiddle by a very
good fiddle player yeah no I think he
was with tactical there's a tactical
yeah you know he's just like oh look
you're gonna run down the street blazing
go gun blazing and then we'll go one mad
squad yes the one man's the one-man
squad she is pretty nice striker great I
love the old map the desert map is cool
but I'd so I just don't know if
familiarity is not there yet right like
competitive shooters a lot of a lot of
it does come down to how familiar you
are with the areas like were you know
you can go and where you can gain
advantages right in the booty
Yassir premium he is on Xbox one Xbox
one X and PC but desert maps not on a
console yet so we have a change of heart
over the scar and the m416 oh yeah I
think yeah I like I like the scar over
the m4 for sure I like the scar and Call
of Duty if there's that's anything but
there's no recoil and Call of Duty so
yeah a chuan how long you play this game
for uh probably another roughly half an
hour so if I'm gonna do a guns blazing
run here and then we'll do well well
finish off with a one-man squad attempt
and then we'll call it a Friday probably
yeah you got some social media duties to
get to and I got some studio to clean up
no can't be here forever unfortunately
all right Roz Hawk but [ __ ] the school
I'm personally you know if I think about
it the other town it is like a pinky but
it's more like a yes and I almost I'm
not gonna do school okay you know what
no I'm too late for school I'm too late
for school
okay okay too late for school yeah why
even go at that point right right I'm
just gonna go to mansions you know what
we'll just take this corner yes that's
fine guys night yes Maya alright uh see
anyone yet but it's pry too high up to
tell ya I mean has San Juan yeah no
she's not close a couple times
yeah fifteen and thirty some some low
teens no kills no kills but hey we were
still looting it's not our fault if
we're looting Wow
nobody's here Oh digital tiger symbol
seven says play the brilliant Rainbow
six siege instead you'll definitely have
more fun maybe like I said Mike has been
binging his way through
Rainbow six lately and January is a slow
month till kind of towards the middle to
end of it so her
don't understand because you don't you
skip leg day yeah why did why did I get
hurt I just dropped normally I don't
know do you actually a manual parachute
because I think the first time I did it
Jake was like I'll just let it do it by
itself I was like oh okay
it depends where I'm going and how far
I'm trying to go if you want to go
farther distance you can put put the
parachute out yourself normally I do
just wait so they've changed the way
that you like that works they I forget
exactly what happened look at they it
used to be if you wanted to get down on
the ground first it made the most sense
to just go fly straight down and to get
on the ground first but I I don't know I
think it's I think something has changed
recently because last night I was
playing with my friends and they were
all like no we want to go first a really
far distance I'll take this right now so
pull the parachute earlier I think flow
to it pull it over I'll take it I guess
I might be wrong like I said I'm not
really sure alright real helmet
um yeah it depends on how you want to
get to where you're going
and where you're going like if you were
like dropping it towards school like you
probably just wait mini-14 tell me I
know is that you should probably be
careful just because there's a couple of
those other people that drop down here
with you right yeah I haven't heard
footsteps I just meant in general yeah
they're like probably over looting by
the some guy by Church so and then
somebody over towards the edge of town
Sam is literally running the circles
it's kind of what we do to loot
definitely eluded that one already yeah
or that one I hope you guys have a
blessed life thanks ghost
Artorius I hope your life is hashtag
blessed hashtag blessed yeah you know
I've been waiting for the day that Evan
finds out evidence are our social team
lead yep and we like to yeah he's like
well you know like our genie mm-hmm
big boats yeah are you guys still
putting all the hashtag blessed post-it
notes on his desk yes it's no it's not
him it we're just like busting his chops
regularly but he doesn't realize who it
is so like but I've been most of the
things that have ended up on his desk in
the last year have been me Wow way to
just expose yourself on stream well so
Evans definitely not watching this like
1 million percent of walk-ins
I'm gonna go message to us Evans
probably in a meeting right now and
there's no I didn't look if you're
watching this hashtag blessed okay yeah
sorry Fred no worries I don't even want
to turn I would probably be a lot worse
and or yeah heard turning up the volume
for you
somebody's building yeah they are
probably above you
it's kind of messy it's a little
excessive Oh Mike what was he thinking
like I don't know does he not see it oh
my Jessop doing your things for the kind
words you guys are good to go I love you
boy
I'm gonna crawl into this bathroom
oh crap someone's here was it farik's
farik's a cat yes you can play this game
as a team up to four people yeah how do
you take I would probably be a lot worse
as a comparative degree and I called her
bad who said that our Turkish at urges
yeah of course
Artur just I'm just gonna keep
butchering your name we're throwing me
under the bus like that all right we got
to kill though we're on the board yeah I
like a mouse a little bit too sensitive
for me actually
that's no you know what it is it's like
almost like real life you know like you
didn't know how how much recoil there
was gonna be a menu adjusted for it yes
that's exactly what the thought process
was there I I suppose you could take it
that way our gist I guess I don't know
how else I would have said it though I
would I guess I guess the really bad way
to say for myself would be
I suck at the game you don't want to
watch me there you go I'm just so
somebody I'm imagine that that was the
person who was either I want to say that
was the person at the church because the
person who's on the edge of town I yeah
there's really no way to tell I'm closer
to the church so I'm just going with it
okay but
[Music]
I'm gonna drop this pistol in a minute
it's really unnecessary to have uh mr.
Smith's I tried to follow Sam on Twitter
but show someone else's Twitter name dat
Tim light hammer no she's just at light
no no underscore I'm sorry oh there's an
underscore there is somebody else is
also like hammer tricked me
Tim light hammer underscore I'm sorry
guys light hammer underscore Tim was
okay he has not tweeted since like 2007
or something like that you know this
person no I have no idea who he is he
just had it before you
he's had it before me does he also spell
his last name that's a what you do I
don't know no I don't think so I'll take
a look I don't think it's a last name
thing Kyle Freitas no news outside of
like what we heard yesterday about pub G
being on ps4 other than the fact that
you know there's a chance obviously I'm
sure they want it on as many platforms
as possible yeah Wow
Jasper Jasper Mauro says if you guys win
this game I will games
I will tattoo GameSpot into my first
board its children's forehead no no
you're not I you know I actually don't
want to scream I know I want you to do
it and I want to screenshot it and so
that if and when Jasper morrow has their
firstborn child I want to see that game
spot tattoo you screenshot this chat
remember this day Jasper forever when
Sam wins her first chicken dinner of the
day and your baby will then therefore be
a the game swap baby oh man
I feel bad for that baby why you imagine
get to live your life and that's like
what you had well you know they're gonna
have to talk to their father eight
excope on a mini 14 yeah we're gonna
definitely be doing doing that she's
dead unless you get the car I think I'm
gonna soup up this p90 - okay
are you gonna make the circle someone
saying you wait yeah okay yeah you're
like right outside my marker oh yeah
you're pretty far yeah it's okay well
strip for these houses we might wow
another a tax no 2x we want that I don't
I'm gonna take it just because y'all
needed to exit some point all right oh I
always do that
it's the dolphin diving card I always
end up doing that instead of putting a
mic on I always prone it's an accident
she likes to collect accessories all
right yeah you guys should have known
this by that it's all it's all about
having a million useless attachments
I'll never use you never know you never
know there was that other time where
you're like oh see good thing I had
these attachments see it actually works
out so the thing is I please I play
mostly squads
I played solo sometimes if I'm bored but
I really play mostly squads and I pick
up all the attachments because in the
end you know you drop all your
attachments and then all your friends
are like really excited and they're like
oh my god there's a car over there I'm
gonna try to steal it
Malcomb rent car brendensen car cenar
sorry butchered your last name if you
could choose what two guns would you
pick to head into the top ten one two
ends yeah tops your top two guns if
you're in the top ten what they would
they be we got a car
yes
oh my god this car is busted
well you're racing the circle you need
this more deep it's got to be faster
than you running right yeah I think so
Oh God Oh still good there they're gonna
be bones all right or not it was bait
the car was bait yeah the subway that
guy's got to be that also okay probably
gonna die let's see where you'll see how
far behind you
someone shot the tires out before they
left it as a trap there it is
thanks better I don't I didn't notice it
at all the two wagons she needed the car
then sorry sorry no the two weapons I
would like one end with I really am
oh he saw me getting the busted vehicle
he saw it he was driving that can't be
right okay that aim was horrible he's
off by a mile now they're not dying they
got a pond Wow all right well won't you
queue for that one man squad that's fine
we wanted to get into the one-man squad
anyways your true form
maybe it's my little pitiful broken car
that I decided to get it was but but
that wasn't totally true Ben because
that person didn't actually shoot out
the tire it just someone else might have
so yeah they're like oh wow look at look
at this truck crawling back to my
unpopular pic so the double-barrel
shotgun really so because you can just
like boom just like one shot but you
know I changed my mind okay just like a
rifle and auto rifle I guess I think
it's something that just has not oh sure
that's and you're good yeah seven six
GMO or five five six Auto them down I
don't know what I want I think I I think
if it was me even though I don't play
very much probably the same auto rifle
and then like an SMG or something I
really like the four sniper rifles like
SKS is probably my favorite it is so
smooth there's no like recoil I just I
feel like I so there's a few guns I like
but the SMG I like the UMP
for the shotguns I like that's 12 K like
I've got no chakra yeah I've won before
well okay so like I don't know that's
cool all right this is one man squad
yeah okay good luck to us may set your
predictions all right we can either do
the afk job where we go to very I don't
know you do whatever you want to do if
you want to go first job
that's up to you or like you just try to
do as fast as I can
yeah do what feels right in your heart
well you know this is this is okay if we
can kill a squad hey that's already
winning the game you will be the
Punisher emption for the shenanigans you
guys watched that's all right okay
Hazara I'm guessing you're saying tuning
in from one as Laila Venezuela thank you
I cannot read either but uh thank you
for tuning in for grip first aid though
that's good it's always good to have
first aid oh and a vest and pants yeah
definitely any pants for now all right
should I take these no I did not all
right seem to always find a shotgun
though yeah they're around they're so
popular yes so far we have one kill to
our name or her name look good you can
that's your victory to your there moral
support matters yes feeling good I'm
feeling good about this run let's see
yeah yes now we now other players might
be on the same team we know we know we
wanted to give Sam the ultimate test
which was to my legs oh wow that didn't
okay second story chops are fine it's
it's weird sometimes I think like when
you fall off rocks and stuff it
registers it as later we got here what
do we got here a suppressor for the
handgun and then oh my favorite handgun
brilliant I'm good you guys didn't see
that
alright slow reload one bullet at a time
it's actually really good somebody they
don't have a helmet or vest on you can
kill them in one shot
all right striker is betting on us to
win but he's only betting a dime but
that's better than what you thought
earlier yeah before you call me trash
now we're worth a dime yes I've earned a
dime that's what you know ash wants you
to get bloodthirsty and kill some more
people where'd you go we're gonna try I
should have done what I could do is just
like in a car yeah we're definitely
doing that I think you have like an
attachment for it I'm not sure hey I'm
as nice
it's pretty solid you know I take I take
it back what I said about like any old
on a rifle probably okay I like it
Mike one Eric zero yes that's correct
the mike has is winning in this the Mike
one
yeah the mic the mic is currently ahead
of me in score all right oh yes with a
pixel
yeah we're not afraid we're just gonna
bandage out in the open I don't even I
didn't even and forth whoo I was like
please I was like please not like this
Sam I don't want to see it happen not
like that as I and I didn't want to say
anything while you're shooting because I
could have just you know I know I should
have like thanks Deb Jenkins for subbing
and they also like this game quite a bit
single kill saved so he died instantly
which means he's not with a squad unless
his squad yeah maybe he's got some stuff
I don't know oh he's got first-aid an
energy drink and red dot aún peor that
oh the SKS okay we'll do this kiss me
cam I don't know why I'm taking all that
9 millimeter but you know it's for that
p9 to do oh wait I don't even have it I
need to in this game at this yeah you're
all right I'll get rid of some of this
stuff in a minute good kill but close
one yeah you know nothing like getting a
race getting your heart racing though
like a real close showdown dual angle
just wants you to do the SKS but that's
fine whatever I like the UM PE yeah you
might want to reload your aka later team
yeah Sam no who's hey is now yeah she
found out I figured it out so ok I did
know who you were
they just this was this was all
propagated by God yep good old gauge he
instilled out in my heart and then I was
like do I know who day is that's right
and I didn't but I
you yeah no yeah you do yeah exactly but
uh the secret's out I guess yes level
two
we still need a helmet
I'm just kind of looting all over the
place no rhyme or reason whoo that's
pretty tough Steph judges really wishes
he could play on PC but he needs to
upgrade it so so far he's having to play
on the Xbox oh that's rough man it sucks
but hey at least you get to still enjoy
the game it's just I mean I imagine that
right now playing squads on Xbox is
probably really fun because it's just so
stupid that you're probably getting like
a lot of people are just getting kills
it with like vehicles and stuff yes it's
like aiming so hard you might as well
just run someone over
so far so good got some quality weapons
got a kill we're not sure if we're gonna
run into any squads but we will find out
soon I guess
I only need seven six we are playing I
love when all your guns ammo that makes
me so happy so I'm just like oh seven
six - great I'll just take all the seven
six - do you guys play csgo
I haven't in a long time I also have not
played csgo in a long time I played it
for a while I don't know well I I think
I just didn't continue to play because I
didn't have friends to play with so I
just made it these warehouses look like
they're kind of spooky like there might
be people in there but okay are we far
from the circle you can check later it's
safe we're probably in it there's no uh
yeah we are oh cool yeah there's there's
no like like warning yeah I figured what
it's called it's like a line that tells
you the direction in which to run
straight towards the circle we have here
- 12 K which I love those things I love
them so much we got we got solid weapons
yeah I thought oh they came on Auto is
great like there's no need for me to
switch to an s12 it's not really like an
upgrade in any way shape or form and
then I decide to carry different types a
ammo it's really kind of dumb free
Rick's the cat asking who are the big
Poggi players in the office probably Sam
Jake Nick plays a bunch with Jake used
to be Mike I'm Mike like I said has kind
of gone over to the Rainbow six siege
world I think John Luke plays a little
bit of Poggi Michael hi um I think play
some pub G is Jimmy thing with our tech
editors so there's a good amount of
people that play porgy oh I guess also
been djenka philanthropy okay
those are my footsteps no I don't think
there's anybody in here okay just gonna
get back down that's the same gun okay
all right so you're gonna do now just
chill remember if you win this is the
baby tattoo nice oops
all right let us I don't really know
where to go you just got to find a spot
you can just like Drive do you want to
go I mean I'm in such a tasty spot right
here
yeah I really need to go anywhere
I could drive somewhere if I want to I
don't know you got to make that call
really be for no reason see this is like
like I said to get high up you just
gotta play cool just be passive is just
walk around yeah this is remember you
are playing one-man squad so you could
roll up or like a squad could roll up on
you at any time
yeah you should get a helmet that's true
that's a good point
get yourself fully quit Fest 2018 here
we go yep it is 2018 what's that red
area on the map it's a like it's like a
bombing drop that you don't want to be
in yeah the red zone is just like a
really dangerous place to be which I
thought was mythological in being and it
is not you can't actually die I mean I
see I saw people die before in the red
zone but I had just been through it so
many times that I was no fear yeah fish
for a bit out of the sea while everyone
kills themselves I hear gunshots over
but they're kind of far away
why do you say hi I'm or higham and not
he he had cuz it's hi him he says it
yeah he says Michael hi um so I'll go
with what he says unless he's telling me
the wrong name on purpose and it's a
little long con you know somebody has
told me that I say my name wrong before
really yeah that's like and who the heck
are you it's like I'm pretty sure I know
my last name I say how I want to say it
unfortunately a tip inator that's not
how it works but home alone is a good
movie they wanted you to set up in an
area and set it up like home alone that
would be amazing subject into a scheme
did you have a good Christmas and a good
New Year I deed for but you know my New
Year's was like real real aim I just
hung out with my mom and I actually fell
asleep at eleven o'clock at night so hey
you made it for East Coast East Coast
time I did I did
and then for Christmas I went back to
garbage big pile of trash helmet yes
level one better than level zero we all
start somewhere
Oh crowbar well energy drink alright a
compensator nice alright now if I had a
good scope perch myself somewhere that
was the sound of a plane probably doing
it drop every now and then there's drops
with like better like weapons in it yes
basically special stuff I think she had
the adrenaline syringe last time too
yes which kind of helps there are
technically squads so maybe a whole
squad oh god shadow is it scary you I
was like if that's not what's good oh
Carlos it's part of the game looting is
part of the game you got to set your
elfs to set yourself up for success
hold on I'm like what I hear somebody I
turned up doggy all the way
Alex oh I don't think so either
hanging out full visibility you know
what nobody's over here so oh and this
sucks
DC CEO 209 said nothing nothing lame
about hanging out with moms I love my
mom look we had a good time it's left
it's great another red dot I have two
already so now we're really just missing
either higher tier versions of arm we're
in a better scope I was in here already
okay hook up those little buildings over
there
did you and your mom watch labor we did
not we have not seen ladybird yet pretty
good at first I thought it was GAD she
was gonna ask me that cuz he loves
ladybird he's not like four times or
something
Wow really yeah he does tend to do that
I know he likes to repeat I can't do
that with some movies I don't know how
he does it
there's like very few movies I'd watch
on repeat like that and they're all
really dumb like Zoolander watch it it's
like those movies you don't really have
to pay attention to - yeah
nacho libre that movie is a masterpiece
classic if I ever saw one he's the bass
I think that like one year at e3 I
hadn't rented out like it's like a van
or you know like something like that and
I had like you know video player in it
and I think there was not so very
amazing
I also really loved Tenacious D in the
Pick of Destiny big jack black fan nice
have you watched Jumanji I haven't yeah
you know I've heard really good things
also was the suppressor of the combats
I'm like the suppressors better it's
yeah yeah I I went in knowing that most
people were pretty positive about it but
I didn't really have expectations and it
was a fun movie it was like entertaining
yeah I just say it I people were
knocking on it so hard for some reason
like some people that were that I know
were just like oh it looks like it's
gonna be so dumb and I really I thought
from even the trailers that it looks
like it was gonna be good I don't know I
can't deny that I felt the same way your
friends did at first and then I heard I
think I was like mike rizzo who does our
entertainment stuff and i think he
reviewed Jumanji he had some good things
to say about it and then like more and
more people go to start watching it and
you hear more good things and you're
just like well I was probably gonna
watch it anyways but I'm definitely
gonna watch it now and I do not regret
it
Sarah Jenkins asks when did you start
playing Poggi I haven't really played
puppy I've watched more than I've played
what about you I started playing
gee I want to say sometime about six
months ago nice okay I want to say like
trying to my really good start time it
would have to be sometime this summer
it's past summer do you have a
suppressor for your AR someone said to
equip it
I do yeah I switched out the common okay
cool
DC Co 209 we do cover CES we all have a
small team going over to CES I think
that's next week probably Jimmy and
Michael our tech editors will be there
so stay tuned again swapper for that
stuff I'm sure we will be on the case I
need a scope alright so here's the thing
that we could do
okay what's the thing there's 25 alive I
know I'm thinking about driving over to
this side of the map okay and like just
chilling in these trees somewhere
there's a car right there in front of us
that we get to you
that's not busted
that's really far away so I'm not gonna
go for it I just wish I had I wish had a
good scope looks like try to you know
yeah we could just go that way like I
just I'm thinking like cut through this
area between these two buildings I don't
want to get caught here like when the
circle closes in but the thing is I'm
assuming that the circle is gonna be on
this side I could be wrong we'll see all
right you know what we're just gonna
wait until more people die no no yeah
we're gonna wait until the circle closes
in open I'm just gonna
we'll wait till circle closes in and
then if anything I'll just get in that
car and drive either way but we happen
to be in the middle sort of or in the
next circle then I'll just hang out
yeah Arturia staying in the whole area
north of the mansion is a forest now so
you could technically hide out in the
trees there camp that vehicle oh we're
camping that vehicle looks like a fresh
one if somebody's gonna go for it
they're gonna see me here so I'll just
do that bait the bait the truck 23 alive
randomly I'm hearing the ocean and
seagulls even though we're I mean we're
not that close but we're close to the
shore I don't know if we're ocean and
seagulls books I have another suppressor
because our Turkish can't seem to really
wants you to equip the AR suppressor I
say boo got it
god damn good at sniping in this game I
don't know I haven't seen her sniper yet
you tell me Sam
I'm better at close range okay that's
fair I probably would be too because
there's like bullet drop in this game
right a little bit yeah hashtag blessed
chats got your back is I really am
really specific I don't like the ax
scope I really like the 4x scope and so
I just have limited I don't want to say
I'm bad it's a mean I've killed people
from huh I don't worry about I just
don't do it that often because I really
like specifically like the 4x scope well
everyone plays differently right so
that's a part of the beauty of games so
you play the way you want to it's fine
no one way is correct
apparently the fork scope change and so
did the 8x the 8x can now sue can now
zoom out
just
we can talk now yeah we should have just
titled this pub G ASMR circle is closing
in and it stopped and now what we're
doing okay yeah we got to go to where
you want it yes mm-hmm all right so
let's just do it let's just we're just
gonna go sounds good
Jolly Roger this is player unknowns
battleground it is out PC as well as
Xbox one
we are currently playing on PC we're
making our way past the man she owned
hopefully no one's like just chilling
there they're definitely
I hope they don't shoot into the forests
oh is that a drop
that's the drop we saw
find nothing left now no no point to
stop oh there's a car over there - right
like it was like that's already passed
by it's good it's a war zone I have no
idea where I don't have a great cover I
should have taken that rock so I don't
want to be in the Sun some people don't
like the Sun okay like somebody's gonna
see me from somewhere then maybe you
should move then if you feel that way
alright seventeen alive it's it's
getting that the hurt is being thinned
right now and the play area is gonna
shrink again I think that guy's name is
salty f the car is great cover it's just
that it also draws too much attention
that's true Ben Janka it does draw a lot
of attention that I don't
it also can explode so if somebody sees
me buy it they could just shoot the car
until it explodes then I could die I'm
just trying to see if I can help you
spot I haven't seen anyone other than
that one car that kind of drove I'm not
sure
I
they might but like I would be able to
see them come in when the circle closes
so 12 people will we make top 10 with
one kill away do we have a kill in this
one we do okay sweet here the car
so hard to tell where it's at these
scopes which sucks another drop
I'm not going to about where I'm like I
mean I don't I don't even want it but
like I wish that I had a eye for a
curator before well but this at this
distance I couldn't in a text yeah but
it's alright
Oh somebody's running for it look oh
wait no that's a that's a bird it's a
plane no it's Superman bird 12 let's go
yeah there's actually 11 now
okay the circle is slowly closing now
we'll see do you think it's just gonna
get smaller from where you are you think
is gonna move those new circle oh
there's a lot of people over in that
blue building I don't and you're not
even nervous you're like hold on let me
fix my hair it was like nope it's not
her
oh you record in terms of this dream yes
but she got seven oh there's someone
behind you I see him okay
we're getting pinched
but see he is going to be on the outside
of the circle once it closes
what will happen
hoping for GameSpot tattooed baby
like what is he gonna do try to rush me
when the servo was like
and now she lines up the but where did
he go he's like I don't maybe you like
behind the circle is closing right now
what in the world
palms are sweaty mom's sphaghetti you
know we got to do make it the big play
big play to swing it around
[Music]
pop popping popping pills popping OH
oh my god yeah pub deep oh my god
nothing like a hot window oh there's a
guy running towards the blue house from
those trees on the other side yeah from
that way or into whatever he has a blue
house we have shitty scopes number five
okay I'll take good how dare you take I
[Music]
don't know let's just watch the death
camp it's fine
Oh week yeah that was weak that was
those Johnny Five is a lot oh yeah this
is the Nick margarita the snake yeah
there's so many drops here
oh wow he was actually oh look at 12 and
13 they're just waiting oh you heat the
gonna use the pizza gun I'm not even
because I wasn't even thinking about
that direction I thought I was thinking
that everybody that was gonna come for
me was coming from like the other side
and around so I'm like not even I mean
there are a lot of snakes in the in the
field
slithering about so I well uh thanks
everyone for tuning in appreciate it
Sam's first stream here at GameSpot yeah
she did a great job I feel like we got
in though we got in the top ten you know
thanks Sam for playing today yeah
welcome and watching me run in circles
and loot the same building slice over
and get shot in the back of much times
oh and off road with the van in the
desert and hitting an invisible wall and
to faraway lands it was a blast and I
hope yep see you guys next time every
day at 11 or one more thing do it do the
fun game spot there you go Facebook
Twitter Instagram Apple news if you use
it yep YouTube twitch the youtubes the
twitches you know all that all of the
platforms all of the things and we'll
see you guys next time thanks so much